[Music]
and rules are rules news these I think
this is a [ __ ] rules alright alright
submitted by green cheese green cheese
add some is a school superintendent
accused of committing insurance fraud
after a student has resigned Oh
to help a student did you think after
eating mushrooms so they committed
insurance fraud to help a student yeah I
like it when people do crime for good me
too it makes me feel like like proud of
them I'm watching the movie and I'm
rooting for them yeah Robin Hood yeah
it's like a real-life Batman yeah
because the real got bad guys are the
honest guy
Batman doesn't do krandle [ __ ] out of
someone he's vigilante crime oh this he
is a vigilante he kidnaps people he
kidnaps bad guys oh so technically it's
a crime I just don't see him as a bad
guy because he didn't kill anybody
no he doesn't kind of a I like Dexter
crime where you kill them torture a bad
guy I like that too yeah torture your
bad guys yeah I don't want to do the
torturing I just want to know that it
was handled mmm or like when like oceans
you look like you like you look like a
boss lady you know it's like sending
your henchmen and do the dirty work
that's it thank you you're like the new
ocean six or whatever oceans I haven't
seen any of those films oceans it was
bad right oceans is kind of bad when we
watch like the first give me another
turn it off I mean I'm not the new one
with all the girls we were trying to it
was like it was trying to be too much
like the original oceans but then they
didn't do a good job of copying it so it
was like trying to be too much of its
own thing and a copy at the same dude
that's what I thought about the new
Ghostbusters with all the chicks in it
there's the same [ __ ] the new
Ghostbusters though I will say this a
[ __ ] Leslie Jones making me die
laughs you know she's [ __ ] funny
you know we saw her when we went to
Bobby Lee's first show she was there she
said hi to her I was like oh yeah cuz
like those films too like I don't really
look for I just look for like the small
bits that will make me laugh and keep me
entertained yeah other than that if I
try to like judge it as a film film it's
not gonna know they're not films oh yeah
I just looking at like some there has to
be one funny part like like the
that's like comic film that made me
super laughs was the one with Jason
Bateman
oh yeah game night it's a good movie by
itself it's always just thought ocean's
8 was just gonna be good like Ocean's
eleven but it just wasn't oh it's a fun
movie liking it so back to this story
here which has nothing to do we're we're
talking about at all ever
classic JK music alright so this teacher
or actually she's a superintendent josh
is the principal of principal
supernintendo timers superintendent so
this takes place in indiana her name is
Casey so what she did is that she went
to go check up on this kid who missed
school oh because she was worried about
him because he missed school yeah I feel
like that's kind of below their pay
grade she's taking care of so many
different
well she's if it's a small town place
well wait what's the insurance for our
department oh so she takes him to a
clinic but he was denied care because he
doesn't have insurance and she took him
to another like Medical Center and then
that's where she lied about that kid
being her son so he could get treatment
under her insurance and so he received a
prescription and then the total bill was
two hundred twenty three dollars and but
she got caught and so she was just
apologizing for and she was how old's
this kid I believe 15 now the real
question is that's my question
well it was the was the prescription for
painkillers or was it antibiotics
okay then it's not some shady [ __ ] but
what I think it is is I think there's a
this is just my own personal opinion
some love she got him pregnant and she
got to take him to the doctor oh that's
good that's pretty that's pretty taking
care of one student when you have tens
of thousands of students to look after
it's pretty crazy but it's not only no
but Europe I first superintendent right
you're in charge of all the principals
of the high school the principles of the
middle schools might only
High Schools I'll get to high schools to
Middletown and six Elementary's I mean
it might be like a small town where
everyone knows everyone and it's very
rare for someone to not show up to
school yeah so what is the Super
Nintendo do like what is it what do they
do exactly like what's their [ __ ]
well they oversee all the principal's
and then they also put together like the
learning curriculum and they like they
check all that [ __ ] to get a budget we
can't budgeting from the state they get
like they do all the backend [ __ ]
they're like the president's president
so it's crazy that they're worrying
about once because I that would be what
the school counsellors job is or the
principal's job or maybe even the nurses
job yeah I remember the Simpsons there
was Principal Skinner and on top of that
there was superintendent Chalmers yeah
yeah yeah and you would come around and
[ __ ] in one of the greatest episodes
ever Chalmers comes over to the house
and the house catches fire more that's
[ __ ] amazing
so a little bit more facts right here so
Skinner she realized that this 15 year
old student didn't go to school because
he had a sore throat so she picked him
up took him to all these things right I
already said that so because he got an
infection from eating her out Thursday
night in the past she's brought clothes
for him and helped clean his house so
she was close to this particular student
felt bad for this kid yeah yeah elected
boy
so then after she got the prescription
for him he tore off the label because he
knew it was wrong to have a prescription
under someone else's name so somehow
police received a tip about that
situation and so she she was arrested
I'm guessing it was like the guardians
because the parents they said Guardian
well maybe this kid is in some really
fucked-up situations too retentive felt
really bad so she wants to lie stuff
yeah funny thing is the Guardians didn't
[ __ ] take him to the doctor and get
insurance for him in all this [ __ ] well
yeah well he didn't eat the Guardians
out so the family is saying that what
she did was completely like
unprofessional and that she should have
talked to them first but let me show you
a photo
so she resigned a superintendent and
then this is a video of her talking
about the situation you know I certainly
weighed that a lot in last week as well
and I would love to go back to that
moment and redo it kicking myself why
didn't I do this and why didn't I do
this but in that moment I just was
really worried I knew he had stressed
and I'm a mom and and I knew how
dangerous that was for him and I was
worried that I'm gonna get him treatment
and I'm not saying that was right I'm
really sorry
just it's a crime to care top insurance
fraud for medication first of all
medications over you way over price as
it is right now anyways so it's like
yeah it's so weird that like they're
treating as if she killed someone or
like I think the real issue here is the
system is so [ __ ] up that she had to
do that just so you can get some
antibiotics too [ __ ] cures throat
yeah which I thought was really odd
because if you have a guardian or like
you know you're we've been in the system
they you get free medical so I'm like
how did he not have insurance so I don't
know the rest of his situation but I'm
like and then there's also free clinics
you could go and try to get a
prescription and just pay like 60 bucks
yeah what the hell is gonna the town is
really small and then the town doctors a
raccoon that could be sometimes it's a
cartoon town that makes a lot of sense
sure it could be a cartoon cartoon
Indiana cartoon I'm not having not so
does the judge just have a huge hammer
that comes out of his front pocket yeah
I mean like well what makes me wonder
what what is it that he's always in
trouble that his own parents won't help
him out it means there's so many
different situations yeah like what's
the living situation like I don't know
what's going yeah how bad is this living
situation for her to want to help him
out and feel so bad well for her to go
to his house and help him clean the
house special attention Wow because
there are people out there that adopt
kids for the money and to be you know
true they scan the system and they don't
give a [ __ ] about the kids they're just
like collecting kids what kind of parent
[ __ ] goes out of their way to give a
tip to somebody else for helping out
their kid and [ __ ]
right no that doesn't make any sense I'm
so [ __ ] there is probably more to
this story for sure there's a lot more
I'm hoping it's the first idea that we
thought about the [ __ ] et yup well I
mean not because it's he's it's illegal
because he's young but my 15 year old
self is saying that at the end of the
day I guess it's really just about
insurance fraud which sucks because you
could analyze the intentions and be like
well at least she's trying to do the
right thing on sex effects right but
it's just insurance fund that's what it
is I'm not saying it's dope when you see
the school nurse
can they get you medicine no huh I
looked it I think it's trick you could
just rest on the bed in the nurse's
office and just call the parents to come
pick them up
oh they can give them like aspirin and
[ __ ] can't they I don't think legally
they can I could be wrong but I never
got you Isaac you think he's gonna the
nurse's office a few times and they've
never asked me like do you want me to
give him medicine yeah I said love going
to nurse's office man just chill in
there and then try to avoid yeah it's
[ __ ] chill you go ahead
oh never was I would just take a nap for
one period that plastic on the [ __ ]
bed - it feels like a waterbed yeah man
can't my only one when I was actually
sick you [ __ ] degenerates I'll just
find ways to ditch class I'd be like oh
I have a headache I can't see I'm tired
and then I go down I'm like oh [ __ ] I
was just accident-prone so I was just in
there for like legitimate reasons to do
just all the time you guys are big here
we go that's it forget you have any ate
any food in three days or drank any
water so you just want to go in there
just to get some ice we could melt it on
your tongue you wanted to go because you
wanted to have someone to talk to you
cuz nobody would talk to you no you
wanted to go because you weren't being
fed at home and they give you crackers
in there
that's why damn you're hungry I was
hungry so I would go to the nurse's
office that I mean you know what you
know I know a lot of my your what
classmates or hungry ah they would
collect food that was around lunch what
but they don't they don't give you the
[ __ ] sack peanut butter and jelly
with apple and chocolate milk for the
kids who didn't bring lunch
no do
this is what my mom was talking about
why did you get a ticket I used to [ __ ]
about my lunch because she used to pack
my lunch and she would make a sandwich
by just putting like mustard like in a
circle and then she'd smack Bologna and
then she'd cement good with her hand
then she [ __ ] put it in the thing so
it was always like I got a sales with a
[ __ ] fist print in it I feel like she
[ __ ] hated you as a child because she
was making quick as [ __ ] for kid so she
was like - so then I was like my lunch
sucks the King [ __ ] trade the [ __ ] I
can't be treated with anybody cause they
look at my lunch is the bottom of the
food chain she's like we good lucky and
get lunch at all she's talking about you
yeah but you know what's interesting so
in our elementary school so if you
forgot to bring your lunch money or the
ticket or whatever they always had
backup lunch for those kids so it was
like a peanut butter and jelly and apple
and like some milk and they would sit
yeah and I always wanted that [ __ ]
life oh I would have traded it for that
lunch so I'm like what the [ __ ] I've
never get peanut butter in jail it's not
gonna get better lunch in the [ __ ]
regular lunch is it the one with the
squeeze pack it has both of them and
then you can move in yeah that's what I
think the people in the school like if I
look back at it now I don't think it was
a part of the school they would just
make it just in case for you I'll be out
of their own pockets and lunch ladies
we're doing this cuz sometimes I would
forget my ticket I would leave it at
home and I would just get that on
purpose you know what my favorite thing
to do is you know at the end of the year
you get
earthquake pack oh I never had that but
you never have to make her you mentioned
it before oh I love to eat remember that
you have to pull it cut like the things
that will last a long time like can to
an hour or whatever I always wanted
someone else's I loved eating this even
though if it was like the same crackers
and stuff
[Music]